I started teaching myself how to
program around the age of 12, and
quickly fell in love with web
development, specifically.
I got my first freelancing gig in 1996,
so I've survived quite a lot of
changes as the web has evolved.
As developers we're learning
pretty difficult concepts and
solving hard problems all the time.
The best was to accomplish
this is to get into the zone,
where time just flies by and you're
highly engaged in what you're doing.
To get to that point, you have to
be comfortable in your environment.
>From keyboard shortcuts and
color schemes to window positions.
When I'm working on a new project or
learning something new,
I always place my windows in
the exact same position on-screen.
My editor taking up the left half.
A browser taking up the right half.
And my terminal, up and running, so
I can easily get to it
with a keyboard shortcut.
>> Even experienced programmers
are constantly learning new things.
As Mike explained, setting up your
workspace for success is key.
Next, we'll give you some tips and
walk you through how to set up
your own personal workspace.
To start we'll make sure Python is
installed properly on your computer.